[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hi guys all right I'm gonna take a cue
from from Laurie stalk and get a selfie
because pics if it didn't happen
cool all right so let's talk to you a
little bit about es6 in practice but
first a little bit about me
so I am first and foremost a father a
stepfather and a husband
I run Santa Barbara JavaScript which is
our local meetup up in Santa Barbara as
Sonia mentioned I'm an avid scuba diver
and underwater photographer and I'm
president of paradise dive Club I've
been building and shipping software
professionally for a little over two
decades now and I'm currently staff
engineer at pro core technologies
building a software that builds the
world it is I can say hands-down the
best job I've ever had we're always
looking for good people so see me in the
hallway if you're interested we'll talk
more all right so enough about me before
we dig into es6
before we find out what this is all
about let's take a moment for a brief
history of the language so in the
beginning there was mocha and it was
released and they called it live script
but the marketing gods had to be
appeased and recruiters weren't confused
enough already
so they renamed it javascript and they
saw that it was good
so they standardized it but javascript
was a registered trademark of netscape
corporation so how about web script or
maybe browser script or Brendan Eich
site scheme as one of the major
influences on the language well maybe
instead let's call it something really
nasty
sounds like eczema what we ended up with
was ACMA script magma for those who
don't know is the european computer
manufacturers association they're the
standardizing body manages ekam script
so we got actor script one
and then we got version two and then we
got version three and then we got
version four well actually version four
didn't happen the eat the committee the
tc39 committee split into warring
factions and couldn't agree on what
should be in yes four but they
eventually extended an olive branch and
came up with a compromise that ended up
being version five and then we got
version 2015 wait what the actual name
of the language is act math two six two
fifth edition six edition sorry echo
script 2015 it rolls right off the
tongue regardless of what it's called
it made a big splash and people were
really excited about this new spec but
why did I care well I've been using Java
scripts into the first game Allen in
1995 and I've been following the spec
for a while and was really interested in
getting in on this new hotness so I
figured like most things the best way to
learn it was to teach so I went back to
my JavaScript meet up and gave a
three-part series of in-depth talks and
hands-on coding exercises to learn es6
and then with a head full of knowledge I
got the bright idea to introduce the s6
to the enterprise nope not that
enterprise this kind of enterprise and
those of you who have worked in an
enterprise software company know that we
often do things by committee into the
case of my last employer
this meant the enterprise software
architecture committee comprised mostly
of former and current back-end
developers whose default stances Java
Script sucks so needless to say they
were dubious and they asked me lots of
questions like can't we just wait until
the specs fully implemented then I was
like well we could but this is not like
the rollout of es5 for one thing
browsers are evergreen now and we have
amazing tools like Babel that will let
us use the features of tomorrow today
but there was still a lot of fear
uncertainty doubt so I waited and I
evangelized every moment I could and I
waited some more until finally one day
in one of these meetings of the
enterprise software architecture
committee es6 was approved
well at that point I was really
interested in having teams opt in
without worrying about the plumbing and
we were using grunt at the time with
lots of duplicated configs across
applications there was already an effort
underway to consolidate those config so
I piggybacked on that we published an
NPM package the teams could install and
get es6 features for free oh all good
right well that time we were also
weaning ourselves off Bower which was
the dominant package manager for the
client at the time and we decided to
move to JSP m which is a noble that
failed experiment and poly filling
module loading in the browser
the problem with JSP m is that not only
does it want to load modules in the
browser I wants to transpile them there
as well which you might imagine is
really slow but at Build time it uses
node uses babel and it's fast so I just
offset the transpiling
to grunt and I have grunt and Babel for
development and JSP and babble at Build
time so now my developers are pumped
everyone stoked we're ready to conquer
the world but there's still one problem
and that is most of them haven't been
following the spec like I have and some
of them don't even know that es6 is a
thing so I put my teaching hat back on
and I gave a condensed version of es6 in
depth for the enterprise then I used
code reviews as an opportunity to
suggest es6 syntax and features to solve
problems that were already on the table
slowly but surely it started to sink in
until a couple of months later our first
es6 code was deployed to production so
what's the big deal who cares
well we're talking about javascript
javascript is arguably the most
misunderstood language in widespread use
it's also arguably the most important by
virtue of its magnitude of deployment
alone it's not just in browsers anymore
it's been for a while now viable on the
server it's a first-class citizen in
databases automation tools and even
operating systems at this point and it's
the undisputed king of the web and it
continues to eat the rest of the world
so let's talk about what's new what's in
es6 so this was the first major update
in the languages history really since
1995 and you can break down the updates
into three broad categories
the first is syntax so this is new ways
of expressing existing behavior that the
language already has we get things like
rest spread D structuring block scoping
arrow functions and modules the second
broad category of updates are
enhancements so these are ants mints -
built-ins or the standard library in
JavaScript so we get some updates to
strings and arrays and objects amongst
others and then the last broad category
of updates are entirely new features and
I'm going to argue later that this is
where the real meat and potatoes of es6
live these are things like symbols
generators proxies and promises it's big
it's a really large update again this
was the first major update in 20 years
of the language can't possibly cover all
of it today so I'm gonna talk about the
things that I think are kind of
important
starting with syntax so we get a you
know a step forward and what we got in
the s5 with the object literal syntax we
get method and property shorthands
computed properties these are a
no-brainer most teams have adopted these
we get default arguments that let you
provide a default for function arguments
there with me I know most modern
programming languages have default
arguments already but javis could we get
this nice little dot dot dot operator
and this guy has a split personality
its first personality is rest which
means it gathers the rest of a functions
arguments together into a true array and
lets you do real array options or
operations on this without borrowing
from a radar prototype so let you do
things like manipulate an array and then
call a base function right went the
opposite of the default value for
example now it's second personality is
spread which does the opposite it
spreads out elements in a collection if
you will here's an array with the spread
operator being used I haven't actually
seen this a lot in production last three
years now but it can also be used to
spread out the arguments to a function
so we see that same example before if
you don't need to provide the value of
this it's an alternative to apply
function dot apply okay let's talk about
the structuring or more concisely D
structuring assignment this feature was
by kind of widely criticised where all
the spec was being worked on mostly due
to examples like this
don't really give any value and just
make the code even more opaque and hard
to read but I think most people would
agree that this is a really readable
syntax this is widespread D structuring
of the named exports of a module it's
also a common pattern and react to D
structure props and you can actually
combine this with default function
arguments for a really concise and
expressive way to provide sort of you
know a consistent API for functions if
you will Doug Crockford is really big
onto this pattern let's talk about block
scoping so up until 2015 we had exactly
two scopes in JavaScript global scope
and the lexical of function scope so
even though curly brackets like this is
a perfectly valid block in es5 this
doesn't do anything the variable name is
hoisted and just gets reassigned
but in es6 with the let operator we
actually get block scoping it doesn't
look like this would be useful but it
this can actually replace the if e or
immediately vote function expression if
you need to do setup without polluting
the global scope the other block scope
right before we move on to that the
other thing this can solve although I
still don't recommend doing this is the
problem you get with creating functions
in a loop this is the classic closure
problem and this is a question that I've
given in interviews in the past quite a
bit and people have given me [ __ ] about
it because it's a contrived example I'm
never going to see code like this in
production but I got vindicated when a
problem just like this came up in
production and the dev who found it and
the only reason I recognized it so fast
because it's because it looked like
Tim's interview question but those who
don't know this is basically going to
close over the variable I and every
function that gets executed in that
array will be the value of five at the
end which is five the value of I so in
es5 or below the only way to solve this
is to force a valuation of that variable
during the iteration either with an e or
a separate function in es6 block scoping
will create a new instance of that
variable every time again I don't
recommend that you do this but this can
solve the problems worried if you find
yourself in that position the other
block scoped operator would get as Const
which presumably is short for constant
and we would be I think reasonable and
assuming that a constant
mutated but we'd be wrong because const
is not immutable accounts is only a
mutable assignment not a mutable value
right so any of the properties of an
object that are not primitive can be
mutated it's more of a signal of intent
than actual immutability arrow functions
are important not just because they
provide a nice concise syntax there's an
actual use cases for them Brendan Eich
has said that if he could change one
thing about JavaScript when it first
came out it would be the function
keyword because it's servos we've got
various different flavors of them and in
my opinion they're useful in three
different use cases the first is they're
really good for terse callbacks so when
you're doing a rein manipulation or
promise chaining things like that they
really shine make the code a lot more
readable the second is they retain the
value of this from their enclosing
lexical scope so you don't need to do
crazy things like bar that equals this
or function that binds are still valid
use cases for function dot bind and the
third is that it really shines for
currying or partial application this
gives you a really terse and readable
syntax but as tempting as it is to use
error functions everywhere you can use
function declaration there's a reason
why function function declarations are
still around they are not a golden
hammer
first off they can't be hoisted now this
is not as much of an issue now that we
have actual block scoping but if you're
introducing us into a legacy code base
it's it's a foot gun to look out for and
the other thing is they can't be back
bound I mentioned function bind these
are functions they inherit from function
prototype this is a perfectly legal
operation just won't do anything it
won't actually change the value of this
there will always be the value of this
from the closing lexical scope okay
template literals give us a really nice
concise syntax for variable
interpolation we used to do lots of
tricks like this in the s52 tokenize a
string just by borrowing join from array
and passing your token as the argument
to it now we get something that actually
signifies the intent and is a little
easier to read
they also potentially can replace even
the simplest of templating libraries a
lot of people don't even realize that
lodash and its predecessor underscore
actually have a micro templating engine
included it's the one you use when you
don't want to reach for handlebars to
mustache or something heavier weight but
with es6 we can almost entirely drop
this and when you bring in multi-line
string support and tagged template
functions which i'm not going to cover
here but basically it allows you gives
you a way of parsing the strings and
tokens that are passed
into a template you can write your own
templating engine natively and the last
thing that they can do is potentially
solve this double versus single quotes
thing once and for all if you just put
back takes everywhere in your codebase
you get rid of that you also get
character escaping multi-line strings
and all that great stuff for free and
last syntax thing I want to talk about
is modules so JavaScript up until 2015
was basically the only widespread modern
programming language with no concept of
a module system now your modules are a
great best practice they help us
structure our code and have a proper
dependency tree but javascript has had
new modules and its twenty-year history
to this point so the community has been
really creative in stepping in to fill
this gap with things like object name
spacing the immediately invoked function
expression or a variant of that which is
the JavaScript module pattern on the
server we got common Jas and its brother
on the client the asynchronous module
definition as embodied by required Jas
but my personal favorite is script tag
vomit es6
gives us native modules with all of
their glory right and it's awesome right
there's just one problem and that is
that while the syntax made the cut for
the es expect a loader did not so we
have no way until now and I'll touch on
that later to load modules in the
browser so again the community stepped
up to the plate and gave us some
incredible tools to do this right to
parse the dependency tree and turn these
into something that's consumable by a
browser and some of these do additional
things like static analysis and tree
shaking now module loading natively has
just dropped in most major browsers you
can actually load modules without a
polyfill or bundler but traversing a
dependency tree have a large JavaScript
application and actually fetching all
those over HTTP it's prohibitively
expensive so I think you know for the
time being until HTTP 2 and aggressive
module caching or rolled out widely
across the web bundling is probably
still the future ok we've talked about
syntax let's talk about some
enhancements so we got you know a good
set of enhancements to the standard
library of JavaScript what we like to
refer as built-in objects starting with
strings string got a handful most of
these are more about the semantics and
what the expression of intent
any kind of real syntax saving although
stringing out ends red gives you both
array gives us a few additional
enhancements I think the most important
of which are find and find index they
let us kind of reduce our dependency on
libraries like low - an underscore to do
that for us
number got some enhancements and most of
these actually are just moving the local
functions off the window object into a
named module number math got some
significant enhancements and I'm gonna
just put a disclaimer that well some of
you in the room may use these on a
regular basis I don't and impostor
syndrome be damned I'm not afraid to
admit that they're pretty much just
Greek to me all right object got one
functional enhancement but it's an
important one and that's object out of
sign it lets us do mix-ins
natively super cool super easy to
understand there are some caveats though
you want to be careful first off its not
immutable so anything in that target
object any sorry in the source object
that is not a primitive type will be
copying by reference so just be careful
the other is you won't copy properties
that aren't its own so it won't traverse
the dependency tree up the prototype
train if you need that you need a little
extra work on your own alright so we've
talked about syntax we've talked about
enhancements all that stuff's great
there's some really good syntax sugar
there's a nice shortcuts tercer code etc
but ultimately in my opinion the really
important category of updates are the
brand-new features this is what I call
the good stuff in es6 starting with
symbols symbols are a new primitive type
and their primary purpose is to provide
unique and mutable identifiers for
well-known methods and the primary
target audience of browser vendors that
are implementing built-ins so in the
absence of static typing in interfaces
and access modifiers in JavaScript these
provide us a way of predictably defining
expected behaviors on objects semantics
are pretty simple
we call this symbol function it's
actually not a constructor despite the
capital S we get back this immutable
unique symbol here we're using computed
syntax on an object computed property
syntax to reference it and then we get a
nice accompanying little reflection
method to inspect the symbols on an
object one of the side effects of this
are one of the interesting side cases
aside from its main one is you can
actually at
true privacy so here we've got a closure
that returns a constructor and in that
closure we create a new symbol and then
every constructor every instance created
from that constructor gets a truly
private property keyed by that symbol
all right next up is irritable or maybe
iterables iterables is a new interface
in JavaScript we don't have interfaces
in JavaScript but it's a contract and
all of the built-in collections array
strings which are just collections of
characters and the new datatypes map and
set they all implement this so here for
example is the iterator or irritable
irritable the iterable interface
implemented on an array and you
basically just get an iterator back by
calling a method
he'd by the well-known symbol symbol
iterator and then you call next on it
until it's done kind of verbose there's
easier ways to consume it and we
actually got a couple of new syntaxes in
es6 to consume this one of which is four
of four of is like four in on objects
only instead of going over keys it
returns the values and then the spread
operator that we've already seen also
will consume any interval so here we're
going to call the symbol iterator method
on a string get that consider ATAR and
consume it with the spread operator it's
like string dot split with a lot more
characters so you can implement
iterables yourself on any object just by
implementing a method keyed by symbol
iterator and following that interface
you can do it yourself but it turns out
there's a better way and that is
generators so generators are just
functions that can be paused and then
later resumed and they have three main
roles the first role is as producer
producer of what producer of iterables
we can with a generator function return
an iterable from a function and since
functions can be composed and iterables
give us values one of the time when we
ask for them they let us be lazy and
what I mean by that is that we can
compose generator functions too lazily
evaluate collections one at a time and
gate those such that we never go more
than what we're looking for
the second role of generators is as
Zoomers so in addition to yielding
values out generators can actually take
values in so we can do things like
here's a generic consumer that takes an
iterable and some consumer it starts off
the generator and then passes it
everything in that interval to the
consumer this is a contrived example but
there's probably some practical
applications that I just haven't gone to
yet
and the last and most important role of
generators is as co-routines
so these are functions that both take in
and yield values and probably the most
popular implementation of this out in
the open source community is redux saga
for those who aren't familiar with this
it's a side effect library used to
handle asynchronous actions in redux and
basically it's middleware that sits in
between a dispatch and the Redux store
and these directives that redux give you
the call put etc those just handle
resolving promises and feeding the
generator with next when the result of
the promise ok proxies the metaphor from
the web holds up pretty well most people
are familiar with proxy from a web proxy
that sits between you and a web server
and it's actually a pretty good metaphor
it holds up pretty well and when we talk
about proxies in JavaScript what we're
talking about is reflection or more
specifically reflective meta programming
in reflective meta programming comes in
three flavors
the first is introspection so
introspection is the ability to inspect
the structure of a running program and
we've had this since at least es5 with
object keys and going back even further
to es 3 where the object of has own
property the second type of reflective
meta programming is self modification
and we've had this since at least es5
with things like object defined property
and then the last type of reflective
metaprogramming is Inception we all know
that's impossible it's actually
intercession which is the ability to
redefine the semantics of some
operations in a running program this is
where it gets really interesting but
what does that mean in JavaScript well
one of those would be to protential e
intercept a getter and a setter on an
object right and then redefine how that
works and we've been able to do this in
cs5 with object dot defined property
here we go through each of the keys on
the source object and went and then we
find a new object that intercepts that
and we can redefine those semantics so
proxies in es6 give us a slightly terse
or syntax for the same thing they're
traps sort of analogous to traps in an
operating system and in this case it's
one-size-fits-all you do a set and you
get in the target whatever the prop name
is and potentially a value and we can do
interesting things with this like
validation in this example since you
know since we can basically obfuscate
the internals of the object we can do
some interesting things we can embody
common patterns like the facade pattern
so here for example we've got a POJO
plain old JavaScript object that's
wrapping local storage and you use it
just by setting and getting properties
excuse me and the object the
applications here are boundless there's
all sorts of great things that you could
obvious kate behind a simple pojo since
functions are also objects we can
actually intercept function calls so we
can use the the corresponding reflect
API I'm not going to talk about a whole
lot but it maps one to one with the
traps available to a proxy and so here
we can redefine the semantics of a
function this is a an alternate and very
verbose way of doing partial application
of a function so here's the all that all
the traps that you get like the one
that's really interesting here in my
mind is constructed let's you redefine a
constructor so you can do conditional
instantiation of objects you can do
selective data hiding you can do all
sorts of really things including being
paranoid because proxies also come in a
revocable variant so you can issue a
proxy and then at some later point you
can revoke access to it so here we're
going to revoke access whenever anyone
tries to write to a private property
keyed with an underscore and not only is
it paranoid it's rude because we don't
even give an error we just revoke all
right last up is promises es6 brings us
native promises finally or I'll actually
finally didn't make the cut it did drop
in ES 2018 just last month a month
before but we do get native promises
they come in a constructor form we also
get some static methods to return a
promise immediately or handle concurrent
promises we didn't get the ability
either to cancel a promise that's
already underway but on the bright side
you won't ever have any broken promises
but these shortcomings
have led to some criticism in the
community and a lot of people still
prefer libraries like Q or Bluebird for
their promised needs but I would argue
that just like this solved the 80% use
case for querying the Dom without
needing jQuery I think this is also
probably gonna solve the 80% use case
for basic promise usage so all this is
amazing right
but the es expect didn't come without
some controversy there's always people
out there that legitimately or not want
to complain about new things the first
set of controversy came around syntax so
there's a big part of the surface area
in es6 that's just syntactic sugar it's
just new ways of expressing things we
could already do and we had some people
that were in the camp I've I've already
learned the s5 why do I need to learn
all this new syntax it's not giving me
anything new then the other camp was
that effort could have better be spent
on entirely new features versus just
syntax sugar but never underestimate
developer happiness a lot of developers
are coming at JavaScript first through
es6 they like these features and there's
some like me that think they're a great
tourist expression and a time-saver so
if you're developers are happy they're
likely to be more engaged and you should
be happy too and then there's also
statistics there's been quite a few
studies showing a relevant correlation
between the overall lines of code and
the code base and the incidence of
defect so if you can reduce the lines of
code by any means you should see an
accompanying decrease in defect
incidence all right how many people use
source maps anyone used source maps okay
we know we no longer live in a world
where we run the code we write right
we're going through multiple stages of
transformation and along the way source
Maps map the symbols that are produced
all the way back to your original source
letting you debug the code you wrote as
you're troubleshooting but it's not
perfect
this is a game of catch the breakpoint
from some production code I wrote a few
years ago the experience is vastly
superior to console dot log but it's not
perfect yet but by far the single most
controversial single feature in es6 is
classes and I'm here to tell you
definitively three years later that
JavaScript still doesn't have classes I
know if it walks like a duck talks like
a duck
it's not a duck it's just syntax sugar
on top of constructors in the prototype
chain this D sugars into this and this
just disha goes into this so you know
there's really polar opposites on this
topic some people love them some people
hate them there's not a lot of people in
the middle like me they're just sort of
pragmatist and accept them for what they
are on the pro side
it's a tercer syntax I actually admire
the terse syntax I just wish they could
have figured out how to call it
something other than classes and bring
in that kind of the metaphor from class
based oh oh there's a lot of other
benefits but I think the main reason
this was done was to make JavaScript
more approachable to people coming from
class-based or languages like Java and
c-sharp but there's some serious
non-trivial cons as well and I think the
biggest one is that the syntax this new
syntax is so different from the
underlying semantics of prototype chains
that it just confuses those same Oh devs
that came from Java and c-sharp and this
was beautifully illustrated when I gave
my in-depth series during the coding
portion one of the guys was a Java dev
and he just stopped and looked at me it
was like that's not how this works but
they're here to stay I think you know
with major libraries and frameworks like
angular and react disseminating class
syntax everywhere we're stuck with them
so wrapping up why do I think any of
this is important well the main reason I
think that this set of updates
particularly the updates to the built-in
library built in standard library are
important is because they let us go
native further than we could before and
by going native I mean that all things
considered all things being equal I'm a
huge proponent of using a native feature
of a language over it's equivalent in a
library or framework it makes your code
more future-proof it makes it easier for
new debts to understand and it also
reduces potentially a bundle size and so
some of these things that we get with
es6 let us reduce the dependencies we're
going to pull into our bundles deliver
less JavaScript and allow our code to be
future proofed so how much of es6 is
legit and how much of it is just hype I
don't think a lot of it is hype and we
have to remember that es6 is decided by
a committee
and quite a few of these features were
actually originally considered for es4
work on which began right after the es 3
spec was finalized in 1999 so I think we
can safely say that ESX is legit what's
next
well most teams have barely scratched
the surface of what you can do and I'm
just as guilty I think most people
haven't gone beyond syntactic sugar very
few teams have implemented proxies
there's some technical limitations there
as well generators also haven't been
widely used outside of Redux sagas but
I'm a pragmatist so I don't just glom on
to something because it's shiny there's
got to be a tangible reason to use it so
what's next for the language should we
expect some more earth-shattering
life-changing updates like es6 well
probably not because es6 was the last
major update the first and last major
update the language will ever get the
committee decided to move to yearly
incremental releases hence the name yes
2015 and it seems to be working because
yes 2016 had exactly two features the
exponentiation operator and a rate up
for design that includes which left me
feeling gypped because couldn't really
give an in-depth talk on es 2016 yes
2017 was a bit more ambitious it has
features like async and a weight and a
handful of other important features
yes 2018 just dropped in June it
includes promise dot finally finally it
includes object rest spread properties a
synchronous generators some other
important stuff the other versions are
coming yearly we'll start seeing this
thing gradually evolve and then the real
game-changer for all of us is
webassembly webassembly is a bytecode
format for the browser that lets other
languages transpile directly to the
browser and it lets me say something
that I never thought I would say in my
23 years of software development and
that is if you want to do cool things on
the web
learn C and lastly I give you ice cream
what does ice cream have to do with es6
absolutely nothing but my ten-year-old
daughter asked me to include a slide on
ice cream and you don't say no to that
[ __ ] that's all I got
you